voyez en impesanteur l'eau ça se
présente comme ça hop là comme ap ce
qu'ils retournent dans l'espace cinq ans
après son premier séjour sur la station
spatiale internationale pour six mois
sport nourriture repos voyons comment a
évolué la vie quotidienne d'un
cosmonaute à travers les archives de la
télé et on va voir ce qui se passe
justement lorsqu'on parle longtemps
comme ça dans une navette la nourriture
d'abord en 1962 john glenn devient le
premier américain à effectuer un vol
orbital
pendant près de cinq heures deux
cosmonautes tourne autour de la terre et
se ravitaillent bon pour ce qui est du
menu on vous laisse juger prenait son
premier repas au dessus de l'afrique
plus ré de boeuf et de légumes bouillis
extrait d'un tube de matières plastiques
après les tubes en plastique place aux
aliments lyophilisés à partir du milieu
des années 60
plusieurs avantages ils sont plus
pratiques à conserver et moins
encombrant mais là encore pour ce qui
est de la qualité
voilà un jus de pamplemousse dure comme
du bois
il s'agit de le réhydrater l'astronaute
dispose de ciseaux ils coupent
l'extrémité il dispose d'un pistolet
taser pistolets à eau et aborde tous les
vaisseaux spatiaux s'en servir pour
boire directement ou bien pour
réhydrater son jus de fruit ou bien sa
viande
après le repas la toilette mais dans
l'espace pas facile d'utiliser une
douche à cause de la pesanteur
alors à quoi ça ressemble direction
skylab la première station spatiale
américaine lancée en 1973 il y a
également une douche à mort et son
aspirateur à eau à cause de la présente
dans style ap deux jours les cosmonautes
n'oublie pas de s'entretenir
physiquement
filmé à 8 images seconde
les exercices physiques à bord nous
rappelle les vieux films d'autres
fouilles après skylab direction mire la
station soviétique dans les années 90
des scientifiques du monde entier s'y
croisent en 1998 le journal télévisé de
france 2 nous faisait découvrir leur
quotidien pour dormir
chaque nationalité à sa petite technique
chantage pour dormir
on est toujours allongé même quand on
est debout mais pour ne pas s'envoler
il vaut mieux s'attacher les russes
préfèrent les sacs de couchage
la navette américaine elle est équipée
de placards et pour finir la question
comment les cosmonautes font-ils leurs
besoins l'explication est simple elle
est donnée par ce journaliste toujours
en 1998 site du coin wc dans mire et
dans la navette américaine
l'uriné recyclée pour fournir de l'eau
pour combattre les effets de
l'apesanteur
tout est aspiré pendant six mois
toutes ces scènes de vie vont rythmer le
quotidien de thomas pesquet sur l' iss
le cosmonaute sera commandant de bord de
la station
une première pour un français
[Musique]